हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे
रही है?
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है? बताइए
जल्दी से चैट में यस या नो।
ओके थैंक यू। ओके वेरी गुड इवनिंग सलमान।
यस आई एम फाइन।
तो एक मिनट का वेट करते हैं। एक से दो
मिनट का वेट करते हैं ताकि स्टूडेंट्स
ज्वाइन हो जाए। उसके बाद हम अपनी क्लास को
कंटिन्यू करेंगे। एंड आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट
कि थोड़ा सा डिले हो गया। अब की बार क्लास
काफी लेट हो गई। बिकॉज़ आई एम नॉट अवेलेबल।
मेरे को टाइम नहीं मिल पा रहा था। तो
इसीलिए मैं आपकी क्लास शेड्यूल नहीं कर पा
रहा था। बट जैसे मुझे टाइम मिला तो ऑन
प्रायोरिटी आपके क्लास मैंने शेड्यूल की।
तो उसके लिए अगेन मैं माफी चाहूंगा। तो
यस हेलो अमन
इस चीज के एडमिन रिलेटेड जो चीजें हैं वह
नितेश ही देख नितेश सर ही देखते हैं। मैं
जस्ट ओनली ट्रेनिंग पर्पस पर ज्यादा फोकस
करता हूं।
चलिए अच्छी है। अभी तो 11 स्टूडेंट आ गए
हैं। तो मुझे यह बताइए लास्ट सेशन में
एंजॉय किया सबने? अभी तक जो कुछ पढ़ा रहा
हूं सबको मजा आ रहा है फंडामेंटल्स में।
सबको अच्छा लग रहा है। पसंद आ रही है
चीजें।
ओके थोड़ा सा किसी को कोई डाउट है क्या
लास्ट क्लास में तो आप मुझसे पूछ सकते हो
अभी
ओके मैं उनको बोल दूंगा वैसे नितेश सर अभी
अवेलेबल नहीं थे दैट इज व्हाई ही इज़ नॉट
एबल टू आंसर योर क्वेरीज डोंट वरी अगर अभी
चैट देख ली होगी सर ने तो डेफिनेटली दे
विल विल सॉल्व योर प्रॉब्लम
तो फेंटेस्टिंग तो आई होप कि मैं सोच रहा
हूं कि जब जब इस कोर्स को हम कंप्लीट
करेंगे डीईएचई को तो मैं इतनी उम्मीद करता
हूं कि मेरे जो स्टूडेंट्स हैं वो ईजीपीटी
या उससे हाई लेवल के जो सर्टिफिकेशंस है
उनको बहुत ही आसानी से जस्ट घंटों में
उसको क्लियर कर देंगे। बहुत ही आसानी से
उसको क्लियर कर देंगे। यह मेरी उम्मीद है
और आप लोग जहां पर भी जाओगे एज ए माय
स्टूडेंट तो आपके हमेशा डाउट्स क्लियर
रहेंगे और हमेशा आपको कुछ आपको एक अलग
लेवल की नॉलेज होगी। आप एक मतलब कि पूरे
कहते हैं भीड़ में आप अलग दिखोगे कि आप
लोगों ने कुछ ना कुछ अभी फ्री में इतना
अच्छे से सीखा है।
तो चलिए सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं। तो
हम चलते हैं। सबसे पहले मैं आपको बता देता
हूं कि मैंने लास्ट टाइम भी आपको एक
आर्टिकल शेयर किया था। तो एक और आर्टिकल
आपको शेयर कर रहा हूं। फंडामेंटल पार्ट टू
जो ऑलरेडी लास्ट क्लास हमने डे क्लास 47
कवर की थी। तो उसके नोट्स आपको मैं शेयर
कर रहा हूं। तो आप जल्दी से इसको एक काम
करना। अभी सेव कर लेना सेव करके। इसको आप
जल्दी से सेव कर लो। लो मैं आपको चैट में
इनको इसको शेयर कर रहा हूं। लो तो आपको
अगर यह नोट्स अच्छे लग रहे हैं तो इसको
शेयर कीजिए। इनको पढ़िए। आपके बिल्कुल
कंप्लीट नोट्स है। जो भी कुछ मैंने आपको
बताया था सिम पूरी डिटेल्स में नोट्स है
और हमेशा लाइफ टाइम आपके पास रहेंगे। आपको
कुछ भी करने की जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी। बस
जस्ट आपको एक बार क्या करना है कि आपने एक
बार भी लेक्चर देख लिया मेरा। उसके बाद आप
गो थ्रू कीजिए। इनको देखिए एक बार पढ़िए
तो आपके डाउट्स हमेशा आपके क्लियर रहेंगे।
जब भी थोड़ा सा बहुत डाउट लगता है आपको
फंडामेंटल से रिलेटेड। आप इनको नोट्स को
पढ़ लेना, रेफर कर लेना। आपको हमेशा
बिल्कुल सारी चीजें क्लियर हो जाएंगी। देख
सकते हो। बिल्कुल जो भी कुछ मैंने पढ़ाया
था सब कुछ इसमें है। स्टेप बाय स्टेप आपको
काफी डिस्क्रिप्शन दिया गया है। काफी
डिटेल्स में आपको बताया गया है विद इमेजज़
ताकि आपको बोरिंग ना लगे। आपको सारी चीजें
क्लियर हो जाए। तो आप एक बार इनको पढ़ोगे
तो आपके डाउट क्लियर हो जाएंगे। अगर आप
लोगों को यह चीज अगर अच्छी लगी, आपको
नोट्स अच्छे लग रहे हैं तो आप एक काम कर
सकते हो कि आप इन नोट्स को
शेयर कर सकते हो और यहां पर मेरे को जो
मेरी जो आईडी है इसको सब्सक्राइब कर सकते
हो मेरे को ईमेल पर ताकि आप जब भी नेक्स्ट
टाइम मैं शेयर करूंगा तो आप लोगों को
नोटिफिकेशन मिल जाए। जब भी मेरा कोई भी
क्या बोल रहे हैं कि जब भी मेरा कोई भी
नया आर्टिकल्स मैं ल्च करूंगा तो सेम टाइम
आपको वेट नहीं करना पड़ेगा कि नेक्स्ट
क्लास में आपको आर्टिकल्स शेयर करूंगा।
ऑटोमेटिकली आपको नोटिफिकेशन मिल जाएगा नए
आर्टिकल्स का और आप क्या कर पाओगे कि उन
आर्टिकल्स को पढ़ पाओगे काफी। तो अम अममान
शेख सर नोट एप्लीकेशन भी अपलोड होंगे
क्या? तो आगे अपलोड हो जाएंगे। कोई इशू
नहीं लेकिन जब मैं आपको यहां पर प्रोवाइड
कर रहा हूं तो शायद आपको उधर वेट करने की
जरूरत नहीं होनी चाहिए। देखो मैंने आपको
पूरे नोट्स जो मैं पीपीटी में पढ़ा रहा
हूं पीपीटी के साथ-साथ जो भी डिस्क्रिप्शन
है जो भी डिटेल्स में नोट्स हैं मैं उनको
यहां पर एक्सप्लेन कर दिया। तो आई होप
आपको जो जहां पर आपको एप्लीकेशनेशंस में
कई बार लॉग इन के इशू होते हैं। बाकी सारे
जो इशूज़ होते हैं उसकी जरूरत नहीं भी पड़े
तो आप यहां से भी पढ़ सकते हो इन नोट्स
को। बाकी इन एप्लीकेशनेशंस पे हो सकता है
टाइम लग जाए क्योंकि पीपीटीज को अपलोड
करने में मेरी तरफ से डिले हो जाता है
क्योंकि जैसे क्लास कंप्लीट करता हूं उसके
बाद मैं मुझे टाइम लगता है तो इसीलिए यहां
पर आपको इज़ली अवेलेबल होता है ऑन
प्रायोरिटी मैं यहां पर आर्टिकल्स के रूप
में शेयर कर ताकि बहुत सारे स्टूडेंट्स
हैं जो एक्चुअल में पे नहीं करना चाहते और
उनको नोट्स चाहिए तो उनके लिए भी मैंने यह
चीज कर दी है। मीडियम एप्लीकेशनेशंस वर्क
करेगा कोई इशू नहीं है। एप्लीकेशन आराम से
बहुत अच्छे से काम कर रहा है। देखिए मेरा
मीडियम आर्टिकल्स का एप्लीकेशन ओपन हो रखा
है। तो चलिए आज का सेशन स्टार्ट करते हैं।
चलिए सेशन स्टार्ट करें फिर। सेशन को
स्टार्ट करें।
हां मीडियम मीडियम का एप्लीकेशन मेरा काम
कर रहा है।
बहुत बढ़िया। आज इसने फॉलो कर लिया तो
आपको और बहुत सारे आर्टिकल्स बहुत कुछ
देखने को मिलेगा और आई विल ट्राई कि इनके
चेक ऑफ लिस्ट टाइप से या कुछ भी चीजें भी
मैं आपको शेयर करूं डिटेल्स में।
चलिए चलिए आपको मैं ज्यादा टाइम वेस्ट
नहीं करूंगा। स्टूडेंट की जो
बोल बोलते हैं स्टूडेंट्स बहुत कम आए हैं।
देयर आर ओनली 14 स्टूडेंट्स 14 नहीं 13
स्टूडेंट्स। तो ये एक्सपेक्टेशन मैं कभी
भी आप लोगों से नहीं रखता कि इतने कम
स्टूडेंट आए इतनी इंपॉर्टेंट क्लास में।
तो पता नहीं क्यों नहीं आते आप लोग। और आप
बोलोगे फिर से सर एक तो देखो अब की बार
मैं खुद से बोल रहा हूं कि मेरी तरफ से
डिले हुआ है सेशन बट क्या है कि अगर मैं
पिछली क्लास के रिव्यूज देखूं या पिछली
क्लास के व्यूज देखूं तो कुछ खास है नहीं
गाइस क्योंकि उनको देखूं तो वन के तक भी
नहीं आपने 1000 स्टूडेंट्स ने भी अभी तक
नहीं देखा जबकि जो चैनल है 47 43000
स्टूडेंट्स उस पे जस्ट 1000 स्टूडेंट्स भी
उसको नहीं देख रहे थे इसका मतलब या तो
मेरे पढ़ाने में कमी या फिर आप लोग
इंटरेस्टेड नहीं है इस कंटेंट में। आई
डोंट नो कि क्या चल रहा है। चलिए आज का जो
टॉपिक है हमारा कि अभी तक हमारा बायपासिंग
यूएस ही उसका फंडामेंटल था। आज की क्लास
में हम क्या करने वाले हैं
कि आज की क्लास में हमारा रहेगा
टेक्निक्स बायपासिंग टेक्निक्स। हम अगर
टाइम रहा तो हम क्या करेंगे कि मैनुअल और
ऑटोमेटिक दोनों टेक्निक्स आज ही कंप्लीट
कर देंगे। नेक्स्ट सेशन के लिए नहीं
छोड़ेंगे। अगर टाइम
कंप्लीट हो गया मतलब कि टाइम से हम
कंप्लीट नहीं कर पाए तो हो सकता है कि
हमें इसकी क्लास फोर और पार्ट फोर और ले
आना पड़े मैनुअल के ऑटोमेटिक के लिए। बट
आई विल ट्राई कि ऑटोमेटिक में कुछ है नहीं
बताने के लिए। एक टूल है। मैं आपको बता
दूंगा। बट हम कोशिश करेंगे कि आज की क्लास
में फिनिश हो जाए। तो प्लीज आप लास्ट तक
क्लास के बने रहिए। बिल्कुल क्लास को छोड़
के मत जाइए। बिकॉज़ काफी इंटरेस्टिंग सेशन
है। मैं आपको वो चीजें बताऊंगा कि मैनुअल
टेक्निक्स कैसे की जाती हैं। क्योंकि
प्रॉब्लम देखो बायपासिंग यूएस की
टेक्निक्स मैं बताऊंगा कि कब करते हैं।
सारी चीजें मैं आपको बताऊंगा। तो एक बार
ओवरव्यू देखते हैं यूएसए का कि यूएसए के
बारे में फिर से आपको रिफ्रेश कर देता हूं
कि यूएसए इज यूज्ड टू इंश्योर दैट चेंज टू
द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम रिक्वायर्स अप्रूवल
फ्रॉम द एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर और ए यूजर अकाउंट
दैट इज पार्ट ऑफ द लोकल एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
ग्रुप। देखो यूएसई इंश्योर करता है कि अगर
किसी भी यूजर को या किसी भी प्रोसेस को
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के के अंदर कोई भी चेंजेस
करना है खास करके सिस्टम लेवल्स तो उसको
अप्रूवल चाहिए। किससे? या तो
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर से अप्रूवल चाहिए या उस
यूजर अकाउंट से अप्रूवल चाहिए जो लोकल
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ग्रुप का पार्ट है। कहने
का मतलब यह है कि अगर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
लेवल या सिस्टम लेवल चेंजेस आपको परफॉर्म
करने हैं तो यूएससी उसके लिए आपको एक
अप्रूवल आपसे अप्रूवल मांगता है। मतलब
किससे? एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर से या उस यूजर
अकाउंट से जो लोकल एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर का
पार्ट है। जैसे वह उसको अप्रूव करेगा उसको
एडमिन लेवल के एक्सेस मिल जाते हैं। उस
पर्टिकुलर प्रोसेस को, उस पर्टिकुलर
प्रोग्राम को या पर्टिकुलर
एग्जीक्यूटेबल्स को या बाइनरी को। ए नॉन
प्रिविलज्ड यूजर अटेमप्टिंग टू एग्जीक्यूट
ए प्रोग्राम विद एलिवेटेड प्रिविलजेस विल
बी प्र्टेड विद द यूएसी क्रेडेंशियल
प्र्प। यहां पर ध्यान से समझना और मैं
आपको एक्सप्लेन भी करूंगा एग्ज़ांपल के साथ
कि एक नॉन प्रिविलज्ड यूज़र मतलब एक ऐसा
यूज़र जो एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर अकाउंट का पार्ट
नहीं है। जो लोकल एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ग्रुप है
उसका पार्ट नहीं है। मतलब एडमिन नहीं है।
उसके पास प्रिविलजेस है नहीं। अगर वो कोई
ऐसा प्रोग्राम एग्जीक्यूट करना चाहता है
जिसके लिए उसको एलिवेटेड प्रिविलजेस
चाहिए। उसको हाई प्रिविलजेस चाहिए एडमिन
लेवल के। उस केस में जो यूएस आपको प्र्ट
शो करेगा। वो क्रेडेंशियल प्र्प शो करेगा।
अब क्रेडेंशियल प्र्ट किस टाइप का होता
है, मैं आपको दिखाऊंगा। यह जो यूएस
क्रेडेंशियल प्र्प तब आता है कि खास करके
आप जब किसी भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन में काम करते
हो एक बड़ी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन जहां पर एक्टिव
डायरेक्टर का यूज़ किया जाता है। जहां पर
मिनिमम प्रिविलजेस दिए जाते हैं किसी भी
यूज़र्स को। उस केस में आपको नॉर्मली जो
यूएसए का प्र्ट आता है, वह क्रेडेंशियल
प्र्ट आता है रेदर दैन कंसेंट प्र्ट।
कंसेंट प्र्ट सिर्फ उन्हीं के पास आता है
जिनके पास एडमिन लेवल के प्रिलजेस हैं। तो
वेयर एज ए प्रिलज्ड यूजर विल बी प्र्पेड
विद ए कंसेंट प्र्ट। कहने का मतलब यह है
कि अगर एक यूजर है एक यूजर अगर एडमिन या
लोकल एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ग्रुप का पार्ट नहीं
है या वो एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर नहीं है तो उसका
जो यूएसए का जो प्र्प्ट आएगा वो
क्रेडेंशियल वाला प्र्ट आएगा। वो भी मैं
आपको शो करूंगा। अगर दूसरा यूजर जो
प्रिविलेज्ड यूजर है प्रिज्ड मतलब जो
एडमिन लोकल एडमिनिस्टर ग्रुप का पार्ट है
या वो एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स है तो उसके लिए जो
यूएसए का प्र्ट आएगा वो कंसेंट प्र्ट आएगा
यस या नो वाला जो आप पहले देख चुके हैं।
इट इज़ अ वाइटल पार्ट ऑफ मॉडर्न Windows
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम सिक्योरिटी। और ये काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट पार्ट है मॉडर्न Windows
सिस्टम सिक्योरिटी के लिए। एंड डिपेंडिंग
ऑन द टाइप ऑफ रिलीज और एक्सेस यू हैव टू अ
टारगेट सिस्टम Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम द
एक्चुअल यूएस चेंज। यहां पर इस लाइन का
मतलब यह है कि यह डिपेंड करता है कि आपको
किस टाइप का प्र आएगा आपके प्रिलजेस पर कि
आपको
यूजर अकाउंट में किस टाइप के प्रिविलेज
मिले हैं या किस टाइप का एक्सेस मिला है।
आपके पास एडमिन एक्सेस है या नॉन एडमिन
एक्सेस है। उसी के हिसाब से जो यूएस का
प्र्ट है वह चेंज होता है। इस लाइन का
मतलब यह है। नेक्स्ट फॉर एग्जांपल
सिनेरियो यह है। यू आर लॉक्ड इन एज ए यूजर
हु इज द पार्ट ऑफ द लोकल एडमिनिस्टर
ग्रुप। आपने क्या किया? एक आईटी एडमिन
यूजर है। इस नाम से लॉगिन किया और लॉगिन
करते ही आप आपने लॉगिन किया। लॉग इन लॉगिन
होने के बाद आपने देखा कि यू आर द पार्ट
ऑफ द लोकल एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ग्रुप। मतलब जो
ये आईटी एडमिन यूजर है यह लोकल
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ग्रुप का पार्ट है। तो उस
केस में अगर
यू कैन ट्राई टू इंस्टॉल ए प्रोग्राम हु
रिक्वायर्स एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर प्लेजेस। अगर
इस केस में कि आप लोकल एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
ग्रुप का पार्ट हो। उस केस में अगर आपको
कोई ऐसा प्रोग्राम रन करना है जिसको
एलिवेटेड प्रिलेज चाहिए। मतलब एडमिन लेवल
के प्रिलेज चाहिए। उस केस में क्या होता
है? आपको इस टाइप का प्र्प्ट देखने को
मिलता है। इस प्र्प्ट को बोलते हैं हम
कंसेंट फॉर्म जो यूजर से कंफर्मेशन लेने
के लिए यूएसए का जो कौन सा फॉर्म है यह
कंसेंट फॉर्म है। वहीं पर अगर यू आर लॉक्ड
इन एज ए यूजर विद नॉन प्रिविलज्ड अकाउंट।
मतलब आपने लॉगिन किया लेकिन आपके पास
प्रिविलजेस नहीं है। आपके आप क्या है एक
नॉर्मल यूजर हो। आप लोकल एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
ग्रुप का पार्ट नहीं हो या आप
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर नहीं हो। उस केस में क्या
होता है? जब भी आप कोई भी प्रोग्राम
इंस्टॉल करने की कोशिश करोगे अपने लैपटॉप
या अपनी मशीन के अंदर जिसको एडमिन लेवल के
प्रिलिजेस चाहिए उस केस में Windows जो
प्र्प्ट शो करेगा उसको क्रेडेंशियल प्र्प
बोलते हैं यूजर की कंफर्मेशन। यह है आपका
क्रेडेंशियल प्र्प। पीछे वाला जो प्र्प्ट
था वो था आपका कंसेंट प्र्प। ये है आपका
क्रेडेंशियल प्र्प। यहां पर आपको यूजरनेम
और पासवर्ड चाहिए होता है। ये चीज शायद
क्लियर हो गई होगी। दिस इज द डिफरेंस
बिटवीन जो आपको दो दोनों जो फॉर्म है इस
तरीके के दिखाई देते हैं आपको जैसे आपको
देखने को मिल पा रहे होंगे। उसके बाद इसके
अब क्या है कि अटैकर क्या कर सकते हैं?
अटैकर्स कैन बाईपास यूएसी इन ऑर्डर टू
एग्जीक्यूट मिलस एग्जीक्यूटेबल विद
एलिवेटेड प्लेजेस। जो अटैकर्स होते हैं वो
इस यूएस प्र्ट को बाईपास कर सकते हैं। कौन
से वाले को? इसको। पहले वाले को। क्यों
नहीं? क्योंकि पहले वाले यूएससी के लिए
आपको क्या चाहिए? एडमिन के यूजरनेम और
पासवर्ड चाहिए या उस यूजर के पास यूजरनेम
पासवर्ड चाहिए जो लोकल एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर का
पार्ट है। बट अगर वह आपके पास होंगे तो आप
वैसे एडमिन हो जाओगे। ठीक है? तो अगर वह
आपके पास हो जाएंगे तो फिर भी यह वाला
प्र्टी बनता है एक प्रकार से। तो हम कौन
सा बाईपास करने की बात कर रहे हैं? यह
वाला जो आपको देखने को कंस्टेंट फॉर्म तो
अटैकर इसको बाईपास कर सकता है अपने
मिलसियस एग्जीक्यूटेबल को रन करने के लिए।
तो कैसे बायपासिंग यूएसी इन ऑर्डर टू
सक्सेसफुली बायपास यूएसी वी विल नीड टू
हैव एक्सेस टू ए यूजर अकाउंट दैट इज ए
पार्ट ऑफ द लोकल एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ग्रुप ऑन
द Windows टारगेट सिस्टम। अभी मैं जो भी
चीज आपको बता रहा हूं इट इज अ वेरी
वेरीेंट टू परफॉर्म यूएसी बाईपास। अगर
आपको किसी भी यूएसी को बाईपास करना है वो
भी सक्सेसफुली तो सबसे पहली कंडीशन यही है
कि जो यूजर अकाउंट है वो लोकल
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ग्रुप का पार्ट होना चाहिए
या वह एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर होना चाहिए। ओके?
रीज़न इज़ सिंपल। इफ वी आर पार्ट ऑफ़ द लोकल
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ग्रुप, दैट मींस वी हैव द
एबिलिटी टू एग्जीक्यूट प्रोग्राम्स और
सर्टेन कमांड्स विद एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव
विलेजेस। अगर आप लोकल एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
ग्रुप का पार्ट हो गए। इसका मतलब क्या है
कि आप ऐसे आपके पास कुछ ऐसे प्रोग्राम्स
या ऐसे कमांड्स एग्जीक्यूट करने की
एबिलिटी है जिनको एडमिन लेवल के
प्रिविलजेस चाहिए। क्योंकि आपको पता है कि
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर को भी क्या जो एक्स
इंटीग्रिटी टोकन मिलता है वो मीडियम मिलता
है। वो एक स्टैंडर्ड यूजर की तरह ही काम
करता है। लेकिन वो क्या कर सकता है? कोई
भी कमांड या कोई भी प्रोग्राम एग्जीक्यूट
कर सकता है। उसके पास ज्यादा पावर होती है
एक नॉर्मल यूजर से। दैट इज व्हाई सबसे
पहली रिक्वायरमेंट है यूएसए को बाईपास
करने के लिए कि वह यूजर लोकल
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ग्रुप का पार्ट होना चाहिए
या फिर वह एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ही हो। ओके? इन
दिस केस द ओनली प्रॉब्लम इज वी नीड टू
बायपास दैट कंसेंट डायलॉग बॉक्स। पहली
कंडीशन फुलफिल हो गई। तो सेकंड जो
प्रॉब्लम बचती है एक ही प्रॉब्लम है कि
हमें इस कंसेंट फॉर्म को बाईपास करना है।
एंड वी वन थिंग इट इज़ेंट टू नो कीप इन योर
माइंड वी कैन नॉट बायपास यूएससी इफ वी
डोंट एक्सेस टू इफ वी डोंट हैव एक्सेस टू
एन अकाउंट दैट इज द पार्ट ऑफ लोकल
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ग्रुप। हम इस यूएस को
बायपास नहीं कर सकते। अगर हम लोकल
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ग्रुप का पार्ट नहीं है तो
मैं आपको यहां पर कोई भी धोखा नहीं दे
रहा। मैं आपको सच बात बता रहा हूं। मैं
आपको यह नहीं बोल रहा कि आप हर एक यूएस को
बाईपास कर सकते हो। यह दो कंडीशंस हैं।
अगर आपको यूएस बाईपास करना है तो ऐसे ही
नहीं है कि मैं बाकी
YouTube पे क्लासेस की तरह बोल दूं कि हम
कर देंगे, यो कर देंगे। ऐसा कुछ नहीं है।
बिल्कुल जो कुछ बता रहा हूं राइट
इंफॉर्मेशन नोट डाउन कर लेना कि कभी भी आप
यूएससी बाईपास करने की सोच रहे हो तो
कौन-कौन सी कंडीशंस पे आप यूएससी बाईपास
टेक्निक्स का यूज़ कर सकते हो। द लोकल
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ग्रुप ऑन Windows इज़ ए
ग्रुप दैट इज यूज्ड टू असाइन
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव प्लेजेस टू यूजर अकाउंट।
जो लोकल एडमिनिस्टर ग्रुप होता है Windows
के वो एक ऐसा ग्रुप होता है जिसका यूज़
किसी भी एक नॉर्मल यूजर अकाउंट को एडमिन
लेवल के प्रिलिस देने के काम आता है। अगर
एक नॉर्मल यूजर अकाउंट है अगर उसको लोकल
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ग्रुप का हिस्सा बना दिया
जाए तो वह एडमिन एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव
टास्क परफॉर्म कर सकता है। दैट इसका यह
होता है आपका लोकल एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ग्रुप
का मतलब। ओके।
नेक्स्ट
अभी यूएसए के बारे में आपको पहले से पता
है। यह तीन लाइन मैं आपको फिर भी
एक्सप्लेन कर देता हूं। यूएसई अलाउज़ ए
प्रोग्राम टू बी एग्जीक्यूटेड विद
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव प्रिविलजेस क्सक्वेंटली
प्र्पिंग द यूजर फॉर कंफर्मेशन। यह आपको
पता है कि जब भी आप क्या करते हो? किसी भी
प्रोग्राम को एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव रिलीजेस के
साथ रन करना चाहते हो तो यूएसए यूजर
कंफर्मेशन के लिए एक कंसेंट फॉर्म या
क्रेडेंशियल प्र्प शो करता है। यूएसए हैज़
वेरियस इंटीग्रिटी लेवल्स रेंजिंग फ्रॉम
लो टू हाई। ये ये भी आपको पता है कि जो
यूएसए का इंटीग्रिटी लेवल्स हैं लो, हाई,
मीडियम और सिस्टम। ये चार इंटीग्रिटी
लेवल्स हैं जो मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन कर चुका
हूं। इफ यूएस प्रोटेक्शन लेवल इज़ सेट बिलो
हाई। अगर यूएसए का प्रोटेक्शन लेवल हाई से
नीचे है। Windows प्रोग्राम कैन
एग्जीक्यूट विद एलिवेटेड प्रिलजेस विदाउट
प्र्पिंग द यूजर फॉर कंफर्मेशन। ये चीज
मैं एक्सप्लेन कर चुका हूं। इस स्टेटमेंट
से कुछ भी आप कंफ्यूज मत होना जो मैं पहले
बताया था वही है। देयर आर मल्टीपल टूल्स
एंड टेक्निक्स दैट कैन बी यूज्ड टू बायपास
यूएस। वैसे बहुत सारे टूल्स और टेक्निक्स
है जो जिनका यूज़ आप कर सकते हो यूएसई को
बाईपास करने के लिए। हाउएवर द टूल्स एंड
टेक्निक्स यूज्ड विल डिपेंड ऑन वर्जन ऑफ
Windows रनिंग ऑन द टारगेट सिस्टम्स। जो
भी टूल्स और टेक्निक्स आप यूज करोगे किसी
भी टारगेट सिस्टम के ऊपर स्पेशली इन
Windows वो डिपेंड करते हैं कि को आपका
टारगेट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कौन सा है। सर्वर
है या नॉर्मल Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
Windows 7 है, 8 है, 9 है, 10 है, 11 है,
Windows सर्वर 208 है, 12 है, 19 है, 22
है। कौन सा वर्जन है? ये उस पे डिपेंड
करता है आपका बायपास का क्योंकि Windows
में बहुत सारे वर्जनंस हैं, बहुत सारे
कर्नल बिल्ड्स हैं। बहुत कुछ है Windows
में। लinक्स में इतनी चीजें नहीं लेकिन
Windows में ज्यादा ही रिलीज वर्जनंस हैं।
तो नेक्स्ट अभी अटैक सिनेरियो क्या हो
सकता है कि सर आपने बता दिया यूएस बाईपास।
अभी यूएस बाईपास की टेक्निक्स कब-क अप्लाई
होती है? मैं आपको बताता हूं। तो आपको
सबको पता है कि
मेन मोटो क्या होता है हमारा? मेन मोटो
होता है कि जब आपने एक बार किसी भी सिस्टम
के ऊपर एक्सेस ले लिया अपने प्रिविलजेस को
जो नॉन जो लो प्रिविलज थे उनको हाई
प्रिविलज में कन्वर्ट करना मतलब आपके पास
का जो एक्सेस था वो लो यूजर का एक्सेस था
उसको कन्वर्ट करना हाई यूज़र्स में यह मेन
हमारा टास्क होता है। तो यहां पर सिनेरियो
यह है कि आपके पास Windows ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम्स है उसका एक्सेस है आपके पास एंड
यूएस बाईपास टेक्निक्स आर ओनली एप्लीकेबल
व्हेन यू हैव एक्सेस ऑन द मशीन। पहली
कंडीशंस यह है कि यूएस बाईपास टेक्निक्स
आप तभी यूज़ कर सकते हो जब आपके पास उस
मशीन का एक्सेस होगा। उस पर्टिकुलर
Windows मशीन का एक्सेस हो गया। दूसरी
कंडीशंस यह है कि USB को बाईपास तभी कर
पाओगे जब आपको एक्सेस तो मिल गया। एक्सेस
मिलने के बाद भी जो यूज़र्स है वह
पर्टिकुलर यूज़र्स लोकल एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
ग्रुप का पार्ट होना चाहिए या वह
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स होना चाहिए। यह दो
कंडीशंस है। देन ओनली यू कैन बायपास
यूएससी। बिकॉज़ आपको पता है यूएससी का
पर्पज क्या है। इसलिए मुझे यह चीज बताने
की जरूरत नहीं है कि यह दोनों कंडीशन
फुलफिल क्यों करनी है। क्योंकि
फंडामेंटल्स में आपको पता है यूएस का
पर्पज क्या है और कहां पर यूएस काम करता
है। दैट इज व्हाई यह डिपेंड करता है इन दो
ट्रिक्स पर या इन दो रिक्वायरमेंट्स पे।
ये दो रिक्वायरमेंट्स फुलफिल होगी। देन आप
सोच सकते हो कि अभी मैं यहां पर यूएस जैसी
टेक्निक्स का यूज कर सकता हूं। तो अभी
यहां पर सिनेरियो यह है कि इनिशियल एक्सेस
मिल गया है एंड अटैकर मैनेज टू क्रिएट एन
अकाउंट विद इन द एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ग्रुप बट
यूएस इज प्रिवेंटिंग द एग्जीक्यूशन ऑफ एनी
प्लेस। आप बोलोगे सर जब मेरे पास
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर एक्सेस है तो सर मैं
यूएससी बाईपास टेक्निक के बारे में क्यों
सोचूं? तो माय डियर स्टूडेंट्स एक चीज
ध्यान में रखो। आपके पास भले ही
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर एक्सेस है। फॉर एग्जांपल्स
आप क्या चाहते हो कि आप परमानेंट एक्सेस
बनाना चाहते हो या कोई एक ऐसी बैकडोर रन
करना चाहते हो क्योंकि देखो बैकडोर रन
करना है आपको या आपको परमानेंट एक्सेस
चाहिए। पर्सिस्टेंट एक्सेस चाहिए आपको उस
सिस्टम पे। मतलब आप अगर वो जो वनेरेबिलिटी
थी पैच हो भी गई तब भी आप उसको एक्सेस कर
पाओ। तो उस केस में कोई ना कोई तो आपको
खुद का प्रोग्राम रन करना पड़ेगा। वो भी
ऐसा प्रोग्राम्स जिसके पास हाई
प्रिविलेजेस हो। अब बिल्कुल नॉर्मल
प्रिविलजेस वाला प्रोग्राम रन करोगे तो
उसके पास कुछ पावर ही नहीं होगी। कोई
अथॉरिटी नहीं होगी। कोई फायदा नहीं है। तो
इसीलिए अगर आपको इस टाइप का कोई ऐसा
प्रोग्राम रन करना है जिसको एडमिन एक्सेस
चाहिए तो उस केस में क्या होगा? और आपको
पता है भले ही आपके पास एडमिन एक्सेस है
लेकिन जैसे ही आप एडमिन एक्सेस होते हुए
भी आप अगर एडमिन यूजर हो तब भी अगर आप ऐसा
प्रोग्राम रन करोगे जिसके लिए क्या चाहिए?
एडमिन लेवल एक्सेस चाहिए तो उस केस में
क्या होता है? यूएस प्र्ट आता है। वह पॉप
अप आता है। अब वो पॉप अप आया वो पॉप अप
आया तो उसको क्या करना है? आपको यस या नो
करना पड़ेगा। लेकिन एज एन अटैकर्स हम किस
सिचुएशन में होते हैं? हमारे पास जीयूआई
नहीं होता। ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफेस हमारे
पास होता है सीएलआई कमांड लाइन इंटरफेस।
अब कमांड लाइन इंटरफ़ेस में आपने तो क्लिक
कर दिया। क्या आपके पास पॉपअप आएगा? नहीं
आएगा। वो पॉपअप कहां जाएगा? उस यूजर के
पास यूजर को पता चल जाएगा।
कि होके कोई तो प्रोग्राम रन करने की
कोशिश कर रहा है। मैंने तो ऐसा कोई
प्रोग्राम रन नहीं किया। तो उस चीज के लिए
हम क्या यूज़ करते हैं? यूएससी बाईपास
टेक्निक की यूजर को पॉप अप भी ना आए।
हमारे पास ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफेस का
एक्सेस होता नहीं है। हमें सब कुछ सीएलआई
से मैनेज करना है और हमारा काम भी हो जाए।
समझ में आया कि अटैक सिनेरियो क्या है?
एवरीवन कि हम यूएससी बाईपास टेक्निक किस
कंडीशंस में अप्लाई कर सकते हैं। बेसिकली
यह कंडीशंस है। देन ओनली यू कैन अप्लाई
यूएस बायपास टेक्निक्स। अदरवाइज बस इसको
पता करो कि होती क्या है? अप्लाई सब इसी
सिनेरियो में हो सकती है। बताइए एवरीवन
जितने भी स्टूडेंट्स हैं देयर आर 15
स्टूडेंट। 15 मींस मैं बोल सकता हूं कि
देयर आर 12 स्टूडेंट्स। तो मुझे एटलीस्ट
12 यस या नो तो आने चाहिए ना। आई एम
एक्सपेक्टिंग फ्रॉम एवरीवन। अगर नहीं समझ
में आया तो अभी डाउट पूछ सकते हो। अदरवाइज
क्लियर है तो हम आगे बढ़ते हैं।
क्लियर है?
अगर क्लियर है तो चलिए
तो उस केस में क्या है कि अगर आपको
यूएस क्या कर रही है? रोक रही है
एग्जीक्यूशन के लिए। उस केस में आपको क्या
करना पड़ेगा? अटैकर नीड
टू बाईपास यूएससी टू गेट ए फुल्ली फंक्शनल
हाई इंटीग्रिटी लेवल सेल। जैसे मैंने आपको
बताया सबसे बड़ा चैलेंज यही है कि अगर
आपको एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर होते हुए भी कोई ऐसा
प्रोग्राम रन करना है जिसके पास एडम
एक्सेस चाहिए जिसको रन करने के लिए
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव एक्सेस चाहिए या एलिवेटेड
एक्सेस चाहिए। उस केस में आपको यूएस को
बायपास करना ही करना पड़ेगा क्योंकि यह
सबसे बड़ा चैलेंज है और यही हमारा टास्क
है। तो सबसे पहले मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा
ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफेस बेस्ड यूएस बायपास।
हालांकि हमारे किसी काम का नहीं है एज ए
पेंटस्टर बिकॉज़ क्योंकि हमें जीयूआई
एक्सेस नहीं होता। फिर भी समझिए एक ऐसी
टेक्निक्स है। फॉर एग्जांपल्स आप किसी ऐसी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन में काम कर रहे हो। कई बार
आपको आपकी कमांड लाइन प्र्ट बंद है। ठीक
है? मतलब इतना हार्ड हार्ड सिस्टम्स नहीं
है लेकिन मीडियम हार्ड है। तो
अगर आपको उस केस में अपना काम करने के लिए
अगर टर्मिनल चाहिए आपको सीएमडी चाहिए और
सीएमडी कई बार क्या होता है कि जो एडी
एनवायरमेंट होते हैं ना सीएमडी बाय
डिफॉल्ट बंद कर दिए जाते हैं। तो फिर भी
क्या है कि यह वाली एक या दो टेक्निक्स
मैं आपको शो कर रहा हूं। आप अभी
प्रेजेंटली खुद के जो Windows 11 है आपके
पास अभी सर्वर है जो भी कुछ है उस पे भी
अप्लाई करोगे वो काम करेगा वो करता ही
करता है बिकॉज़ आप एक नॉर्मल बिहेवियर को
चेंज कर रहे हो तो वो चीजें मैं आपको
सिखाता हूं 100% काम करेगा तो देखो तो दीज़
एग्जांपल्स आर नॉट यूजली एप्लीकेबल टू
रियल वर्ल्ड सिनेरियोस बिल्कुल सही बात है
क्योंकि एज दे रिलाई ऑन अस हैविंग एक्सेस
टू अ ग्राफिकल सेशन यह रिलाई करते हैं कि
हमारे पास ग्राफिकल सेशन लेकिन हमें आप ही
बताइए कभी भी हमें ग्राफिकल सेशन मिलता है
किसी भी टारगेट पर कभी भी बताइए हमें
ग्राफिकल सेशन मिलता है किसी भी टारगेट के
ऊपर कभी नहीं मिलता इसलिए सबसे पहले
टेक्निक क्या है सबसे पहले टेक्निक है
टेक्निक वन एमएस कॉन्फिग क्या होता देखो
हमारा मेन गोल क्या है टू ऑब्टेन एक्सेस
टू ए हाई इंटीग्रिटी लेवल कमांड प्र्प
विदाउट पासिंग थ्रू यूएस मुझे यूएससी के
थ्रू पास करना नहीं और मुझे क्या करना है
कि मुझे USB प्रना चाहिए लेकिन मुझे मेरे
पास जो कमांड सेल आए वो हाई इंटीग्रिटी
वाला आया कि मेरे पास उसके उसके दबा के
एक्सेस हो तो देख सकते हैं वो भी फर्स्ट
लेट अस स्टार्ट बाय ओपनिंग एमएसएफ कॉन्फिग
आइदर फ्रॉम द स्टार्ट मेनू और द रन मतलब
हम कैसे करेंगे एमएसएफ कॉन्फिग है विंडो
आर करोगे एमएसएफ कॉन्फिग के जैसे ओके
करोगे तो नेक्स्ट क्या होगा जैसे आपने ओके
किया तो अगर मैं एक चीज दिखाता हूं हमने
क्या किया प्रोसेस हैकर होता है मतलब कि
सिस्टम सिस्टम इंटरनल टूल सेट होता है
Microsoft Windows का जो एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
के लिए है। तो उसके अंदर एक प्रोसेसर हैकर
होता है। तो उससे हमने क्या किया? MSF
कॉन्फ़िग प्रोसेस को एनालाइज किया है। और
जैसे ही हमने एनालाइज किया तो हमें कुछ
इंटरेस्टिंग दिखाई दिया। इंटरेस्टिंग क्या
था कि हमें कोई भी यूएस प्र्ट नहीं आया।
बट जो आपका एमएसएफ कॉन्फिग है उसका देख
इंटीग्रिटी लेवल क्या है? हाई। इंटीग्रिटी
लेवल क्या है? उसका हाई है। देखो
इंटीग्रिटी लेवल मैं आपको दिखा रहा हूं।
उसका इंटीग्रिटी लेवल क्या है? हाई है। यह
किसकी वजह से पॉसिबल है? दिस इज पॉसिबल
बिकॉज़ ऑफ ए फीचर कॉल्ड ऑटो एलिवेशन दैट
अलाउ स्पेसिफिक बाइनरीज टू टू एलिवेट
विदाउट रिक्वायरिंग द यूजर इंटरेक्शन। समझ
में आई? क्योंकि मैंने एक चीज आपको बताई
थी। फंडामेंटल्स में एक ऑटो एलिवेशन का
फीचर्स होता है। वो कुछ Windows की बाइनरी
को ही अलाउ किया जाता है जो Windows के
द्वारा साइन की जाती है। साथ के साथ उनके
जो एक्सML फाइल होती है एक्सML फाइल में
ऑटो एलिवेशन इक्वल टू ट्रू होना चाहिए।
कुछ कंडीशंस है वो फुलफिल होने के बाद ही
क्या होता है? यह ऑटो एलिवेशन फीचर इनेबल
होता है। इस केस में क्या होता है कि US
प्रता।
ओके? और ऐसी बहुत सारी चीजें हैं हमारी
Windows के अंदर जितने भी जैसे कि आपने
देखा कंट्रोल पैनल के अंदर कितने सारी
चीजें हैं वो सारे क्या है उनके पास
मैक्सिमम के पास ऑटो एलिवेशन फीचर्स होते
हैं क्योंकि बार-बार उनके लिए प्र्प नहीं
आता तो ऐसे बहुत सारी चीजें हैं जैसे
डिस्क मैनेजमेंट है जैसे बॉस मैं आपको
बताया था ये सारे ऑटो एलिवेशन फीचर
इनेबल्ड के साथ आते हैं तो देखिए तो इफ वी
कुड इनफोर्स एमएसएफ कॉन्फिग टू स्पून अभी
हम क्या करेंगे कि इस तरीके का पॉप अप आता
है हम टूल्स के अंदर जाएंगे जाएंगे वहां
पर क्राउ कमांड प्रॉप्ट के अंदर जाएंगे और
हम क्या करेंगे इसको स्पॉन करेंगे मतलब यह
नॉर्मल बिहेवियर है विंडो का लेकिन हम
इसको क्या करने वाले हैं इसका मिसयूज करने
वाले हैं मतलब इसका जो इसकी काम बिल्कुल
नॉर्मल कर रहा है बट हम हैकर माइंडसेट के
साथ इसको क्या करने वाले हैं इसको स्पॉन
करने वाले हैं इसका मिसयूज करने वाले हैं
और हम क्या करेंगे यहां से कमांड प्र्ट
ओपन करेंगे और यहां से जो कमांड प्र्ट ओपन
होगा वह होगा हाई इंटीग्रिटी लेवल वाला
सेम एक्सेस टोकन मिलेगा जो एक्सेस टोकन
किसका था एमएसएफ कॉन्फिग का जो अभी हमने
देखा था हाई इफ वी क्लिक टू लॉन्च वी विल
ऑब्टेन ए हाई इंटीग्रिटी लेवल कमांड प्र्ट
विदाउट इंटरेक्टिंग विद यूएस इन एनी वे तो
सबसे पहला यह था चलो मैं आपको ये एग्जांपल
क्लियर कर देता हूं तो सबसे पहले हम चलते
हैं मिनिमाइज किया मैं विंडो आर करता हूं
विंडो आर किया तो अभी मैं क्या करता हूं
एमएसएफ कॉन्फिग देखना मेरे पास कोई भी
प्र्ट नहीं आएगा आएगा। यहां देख पा रहे
हो? यह रहा एमएसएफ कॉन्फ़ग। यहां मैं सर्च
कर रहा हूं। मैंने क्लिक किया। हो गया
ओपन। नॉर्मल स्टार्टअप है। देखिए कोई भी
पंप नहीं आया। कुछ भी नहीं। मैं गया टूल
के अंदर। टूल के अंदर में हम सर्च करते
हैं। यहां पर देखो कमांड प्र्ट दिखा रहा
है। कमांड प्र्ट और यहां पर ल्च किया
मैंने। जैसे ल्च किया। देखो ध्यान से यहां
पर अगर आप देखोगे तो यह देखो Windows
सिस्टम 32 अगर मैं कैसे चेक कर सकता हूं?
देखो हु एम आई। उसके बाद मैं चेक कर सकता
हूं। एक कमांड होती थी। हु एम आई हम वेट
ऑन वेट गाइस
कमांड थी हु एम आई सॉरी पहले हम चेक करते
हैं हु एम आई और उसके बाद
ग्रुप देन ग्रुप्स उसके बाद एक कमांड है
फाइंड
लेवल
फाइंड लेवल देखना हिट एंटर क्या लेवल है
हाई इंटीग्रिटी लेवल समझ में आ गया कौन
कौन सा लेवल है?
हाई इंटीग्रिटी लेवल। आप स्टॉप नहीं कर
सकते।
नहीं कर सकते।
और बाकी मैं आपका सवाल समझ नहीं पाया। अगर
आप किससे अगर जो अभी आपको मैं शो कर रहा
हूं अगर आप इससे रिलेटेड क्वेश्चन पूछ रहे
हो तो
इसका मैंने आपको जवाब दे दिया। अगर और कोई
आपका सवाल है तो प्लीज आस्क मी और चैट में
भेज दीजिए। तो चीज क्लियर हो गई सबको? यह
पहले टेक्निक क्लियर है? देखो आपकी मशीन
में मैंने लाइव मेरी खुद की मशीन में
विंडो 11 में दिखा रहा हूं मैं आपको।
क्लियर है ये चीज? इंटरेस्टिंग गाइज़
बताओ जल्दी से बताओ जल्दी-जल्दी।
एक चीज क्लियर है?
किसको पता था यह चीज?
किसको पता था? आपने नॉर्मल बिहेवियर को ही
क्या किया? उसके अपोजिट यूज़ कर लिया। मतलब
मिसयूज़ कर रहे हो उस चीज का। यह तो आपके
लिए दी गई है क्योंकि आप बार-बार आपको
प्र्ट ना आए और आप चीजों के साथ ईजीली काम
कर पाए। आप परेशान ना हो। बट आपने इसका
मिसयज कर लिया। किस-किस को पहले से पता था
यह चीज? यह टेक्निक।
किसी को कोई आईडिया था?
यस या नो? बताइए।
चैट में रिप्लाई लेट करते हो यार।
तो चलिए पता चल गया एक और एक एक टेक्निक
का इसको हम बंद करते हैं। नेक्स्ट
नहीं लो प्रिज्ड यूजर से सेम वर्क नहीं
करेगा।
सीएलआई में कैसे करें? आई विल शो यू। डोंट
वरी। मैं बताऊंगा। सीएलआई का अलग प्रोसेस
होती है। सीएलआई की एक टेक्निक मैं आपको
दिखाऊंगा। उसके बाद जैसे-जैसे हम आगे अपनी
पेन टेस्टिंग जर्नी में आगे बढ़ेंगे।
जैसे-जैसे आप भी अपनी लाइफ में नए-नए
चैलेंज सीखोगे, नए-नए सीटीएफ सॉल्व करोगे,
नए-नए चैलेंज आपको देखने को मिलेंगे, तो
ऑटोमेटिकली आपको चीजें समझ में आ जाएंगी।
Windows में क्या है ना आपका दो चीजें
हैं। फंडामेंटल क्लियर होना चाहिए। आपको
चीजों का पता होना चाहिए। तीसरा आपका कॉमन
सेंस कि आपको यह सोचना है कि यह इसका
नॉर्मल बिहेवियर है। तो मैं इसको कैसे यूज
कर सकता हूं? मतलब मैं अपने मशियस वे से
या मैं एज ए पेंटेस्टस एज ए साइबर
सिक्योरिटी एक्सपर्ट मैं इसको कैसे
मिसयूज कर सकता हूं? यह थिंकिंग आपके पास
होनी चाहिए। यह कोई नॉर्मल बिल्कुल ही
नॉर्मल चीज थी। इसमें कुछ अलग थोड़ी ना
था। बट देखो
देखो बिल्कुल ही अब कर दो किसी का सीएमडी
बैन यह जैसे तो काम कर रहा है क्योंकि
इसने आपको एंट्री दे दी कहां पर सिस्टम 32
के अंदर दैट इज व्हाई टेक्निक नंबर टू है
कि एक और है यह एमjॉमस
यह है कोई एक मैनेजर इसको एक इसके बारे
में सर्च करेंगे तो इस यहां पर भी हमारा
गोल क्या है ऑब्टेन एक्सेस टू ए हाई
इंटीग्रिटी लेवल कमांड प्र्प विदाउट
पासिंग थ्रू यूएससी सेम जैसे हम एमएसएफ
कॉन्फिग में किया था। हम भी चाहते हैं कि
ये जो एजमन डॉट एमएससी विल ऑटो एलिवेट
विदाउट रिक्वायरिंग यूजर इंटरेक्शन। सेम
इससे तो हम चाहते हैं। बट यह थोड़ा
डिफरेंट है। वी कैन फाइंड इफ वी कैन फाइंड
ए वे टू स्पॉन ए सेल फ्रॉम विद इन दैट
प्रोसेस कि हम चाहते हैं कि हम भी इसके
साथ भी कोई एक ऐसा तरीका फाइंड आउट करें
ताकि हम यूएसए को बायपास कर पाए gवाई के
थ्रू। तो पहले देखते हैं azman.msc
देखिए यह क्या है? ऑथराइजेशन मैनेजर है। ए
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
यह देखो यह देख लो। ऑथराइजेशन मैनेजर है।
इज़ द ऑथराइजेशन मैनेजर। ए माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
मैनेजमेंट कंसोल एमएमसी स्नैप इन यूज टू
मैनेज रोल बेस सिक्योरिटी फॉर एप्लीकेशन
ओके
टू ओपन यू कैन प्रेस विंडो आर टाइप प्रेस
सेंटर इट अलाउ एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर टू क्रिएट
रोल्स टास्क असाइन यूज़र्स और ग्रुप्स टू
दोज़ रूल्स टू डिफाइन एप्लीकेशन एक्सेस देख
लिए ध्यान से बिल्कुल तो आपको पता चल गया
कि यह क्या है नेक्स्ट यह कॉन्फ़िगरेशन पाथ
तो हम एक काम करते हैं इसको भी देख इसको
भी करेंगे डोंट वरी कोई चिंता करने की
जरूरत नहीं है। तो इसको देख लेते हैं हम
इसके साथ क्या कैसे हम इसको यूज़ करेंगे।
तो नेक्स्ट जैसे हमने इसको एनालाइज किया
तो जैसे मैंने आपको बताया था प्रोसेस हैकर
MMC. यह भी क्या है? हाई इंटीग्रिटी लेवल
में रन करती है प्रोसेस जो नॉर्मल यह जो
ऑथराइजेशन मैनेजर यह भी हाई इंटीग्रिटी
लेवल के साथ रन करता है। बिकॉज़ ऑफ़ ऑटो
एलिवेशन फीचर इसमें इनेबल है। तो, हम क्या
करने वाले हैं? जैसे ही रन करेंगे, तो इस
तरीके का ऑथराइजेशन मैनेजर आपके सामने खुल
के आ जाता है। तो, हम किसको क्या करेंगे?
अब की बार मिसयूज़ करेंगे इसकी हेल्प
फंक्शनैलिटी का। इसके अंदर एक हेल्प मेनू
है। इसको हम अब्यूज करेंगे। इसको मिसयूज़
करेंगे। कैसे? जैसे इस पे हम क्लिक करते
हैं। जैसे इस पे क्लिक किया तो आपको इस
तरीके की स्क्रीन ओपन हो जाती है। जैसे इस
तरीके की स्क्रीन ओपन होगी तो यहां पे एक
वेब पेज टाइप का दिख रहा है आपको। हम यहां
पर क्या करेंगे इसको? व्यू सोर्स पेज
करेंगे। इसका राइट क्लिक किया। व्यू सोर्स
किया। व्यू सोर्स करते ही क्या होगा? आपको
नोटपैड खुल जाएगा। आपको नोटपैड खुल जाएगा।
और आपको पता है जब नोटपैड खुल जाएगा।
नोटपैड में आप क्या कर सकते हो? फाइल के
अंदर जाओगे। ओपन के अंदर जाओगे और यहां पर
ऑल फाइल सेलेक्ट करोगे। सीएमडी सीएमडी
सेलेक्ट करोगे Windows सिस्टम 32 के अंदर
तो उसको भी आप यहां से ओपन कर सकते हो। आप
चलो इसको मैं लाइव दिखा देता हूं। तो चलो
इसका ये था कॉपी। चलो
विंडो आर इसको कंट्रोल वी ध्यान से देखिए।
ओपन किया नाउ
यह आ गया ऑथराइजेशन मैनेजर यह मेरी हेल्प
फाइल है क्लिक किया यह खुल गया जैसा उधर
विंडो दिखाई दे रहा था ऐसा ही इधर है दिख
गया आपको सबको क्लियर
दिख रहा है सबको और यहां पर मैंने क्या
किया राइट क्लिक राइट क्लिक करते ही व्यू
सोर्स किया देखो व्यू सोर्स करते मेरा
क्या खुल गया नोटपड मेरा खुल गया नोटपड
खुल गया नोटपड दिख रहा है सबको
सबको दिख रहा है नोटपड यहां पर मैं क्या
करूंगा फाइल के अंदर जाऊंगा ओपन पर जाऊंगा
क्योंकि आपका जो फाइल सिस्टम का जो आपका
फाइल मैनेजर है ना यह उसके अंदर नोटपड तो
फाइल पे क्लिक किया ओपन किया जैसे मैंने
ओपन किया मैं किसके अंदर चला गया अपने
फाइल सिस्टम के अंदर फाइल सिस्टम के अंदर
मैं कहां जाऊंगा दिस पीसी डबल क्लिक किया
मैं क्या Windows सिस्टम 32 चलिए हम चलते
हैं Windows सिस्टम 32 अब यहां पर सर्च और
यहां पर टेक्स्ट फाइल नहीं हम ऑल फाइल
सेलेक्ट करेंगे। उसके बाद हम यहां करेंगे
सीएमडी ध्यान से देखो सीमडी.exe सर्च करते
हैं। इधर यहां पर सर्च करते हैं। एक मिनट
देखते हैं कहां आ गया। आया या नहीं आया।
देखो नीचे होगा सीएमडी कहीं पर इधर तो
लेकिन यहां सर्च कर लिया। मतलब यहां दिखा
रहा है। और यह रहा यह रहा क्योंकि इसी के
अंदर आपका सीएमडी
ओके ए बी सी डी टी डी डी सीएमडी
सर्च करते हैं इसमें
सीएमडी
यह रहा दिख गया यहां पर मैंने यहां पर
सर्च किया यह रहा सीएमडी
यहां पर क्या करेंगे हम यहां क्लिक यहां
पर सीएमडी पे क्लिक किया इसको हम डायरेक्ट
ओपन करेंगे जस्ट फिर ओपन करेंगे जस्ट इतना
ही हम ओपन करने वाला हूं जैसे मैंने इसको
ओपन किया ओके आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट
यह तो अलग हो गया प्रॉब्लम। रुको रुको
रुको
नोट मैं सही से नहीं कर पाया।
ओपन
सीएमडी नहीं चाहिए इधर ऑल फाइल्स
और यहां पर हमें ऑल फाइल के अंदर
बहुत सारी फाइल्स है ना इसलिए
यह रहा सीएमडी
देखो यहां पर क्या किया राइट क्लिक किया
और जैसे ही मैं इसको ओपन करूंगा
सिस्टम 32 फिर से हु एम आई
उसके बाद
जो हमारी कमांड थी ग्रुप्स
ग्रुप्स
फाइंड उसके बाद देखो
लेबल
लेबल था ना लेवल था ना
सॉरी व्हाट इज द कमांड
ड एनीवन रिमेंबर
लेबल
ओके ये देखो हाई इंटीग्रिटी लेवल सबको समझ
में आ गया
एवरीवन गॉट क्लियर ये ये थी आपकी टेक्निक
नंबर टू
क्लियर हो गया टेक्निक नंबर नंबर टू
टेक्निक नंबर टू क्लियर हो गया
हम
आगे बढ़े
यह बताओ इसका किसको पता था बताओ
इसका किसको पता
बताओ इसका किस-किस को पता था? यह वाली जो
टेक्निक थी
यस या नो बताइए।
बहुत आराम आराम से सोचते हो आप लोग।
बता दिया करो
हम जिसने मीडियम उसकी ट्राई एककमी पर
सॉल्व किया होगा उस उसको पता होगा यह उस
पे लैब में है यह
चलिए नेक्स्ट
तो यह हमें पता चल गया अभी हम बात करते
हैं सीएलआई बेस्ड यूएस बाईपास कैसे कर
सकते हैं दी एग्जांपल्स आर एप्लीकेबल टू
रियल वर्ल्ड सिनेरियो
अब यह जो सीएलआई बेस्ड यूएससी बाईपास होता
है, यह हमारे लिए बिल्कुल काम का है एज ए
पेंटेस्टर्स। ओके? तो सीएलआई बेस्ड बायपास
के लिए हमारे पास क्या होना चाहिए? लोकल
एनुमरेशन। जैसे मैं आपको डे वन से समझा
रहा था कि हमेशा कई एक तो नॉर्मल एनुमरेशन
होता है और एक पोस्ट एक्सप्लइटेशन में
लोकल एनुमरेशन होता है। और लोकल एनुमरेशन
में अगर आपके पास इनेशन है देन ओनली यू
कैन बाईपास यूएसी। ओके? क्योंकि हमारे पास
विदाउट इंफॉर्मेशन यू कैन नॉट डू एनीथिंग
बिकॉज़
पोस्ट एक्सप्लइटेशन में चीजें आगे तब बढ़ती
हैं जब आपके पास इंफॉर्मेशन है। जब आपके
पास इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं है तो आप ब्लाइंड हो
जाते हो। तो नाउ सिनेरियो यह है कि अटैकर
परफॉर्म ए लोकल एनुमरेशन ऑन टू द टारगेट।
अटैकर ने क्या किया कि टारगेट के ऊपर लोकल
एनिमरेशन परफॉर्म किया और वहां पर एक
इंटरेस्टिंग बाइनरी मिली जिसका नाम था फूड
हेलपर डॉट exc जो ऑटो एलिवेटेड फीचर
जिसमें इनेबल था तो अभी चैलेंज क्या है कि
को बायपास करना है इसका मिसयूज करना है और
अटैकर को क्या चाहिए हाई प्रिलजेस ठीक है
तो कैसे करेंगे वो हम देखते हैं तो सबसे
पहले समझते हैं कि फूड हेल्पर प्रोग्राम
होता क्या है। यह ऑलरेडी एक सीटीएफ है।
ऑलरेडी आप देखोगे प्रीमियम लैब है आपके
यूएस बायपास के अंदर। उसी से एग्जांपल
मैंने लिया है। क्योंकि इससे बेस्ट
एग्जांपल और इससे बेस्ट टेक्निक शायद नहीं
होगी क्योंकि इसको अच्छे से बताया भी जा
सकता है। अदरवाइज इसके लिए आपके लिए आप
प्रैक्टिस करने के लिए आपके पास
प्रैक्टिकल लैब भी नहीं होगी। तो इट इज़ द
बेस्ट। मैंने वहीं से इसको एग्जांपल लिया
है। बट इसको मैंने और ज्यादा एलबोरेट किया
है ताकि मैं आपको समझा सकूं। तो फूड हेलपर
exc इज वन ऑफ द Windows डिफॉल्ट
एग्जीक्यूटेबल इन चार्ज ऑफ मैनेजिंग
Windows ऑप्शनल फीचर्स इंक्लूडिंग एडिशनल
लैंग्वेज एप्लीकेशन नॉट इंस्टॉल्ड बाय
डिफॉल्ट और अदर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
कैरेक्टरिस्टिक्स तो अभी हम बात करें इसकी
के अपने फूड हेलपर exc की तो यह क्या होता
है
यह Windows का बिल्ट इन प्रोग्राम है
Windows का क्या है एक बिल्ट इन प्रोग्राम
है जिसका काम है ऑप्शनल फीचर्स को मैनेज
करना। ऑप्शनल फीचर्स में आता है आपका
एक्स्ट्रा लैंग्वेज पैकेजेस आपके ऑप्शनल
टूल्स होते हैं या वो कंपोनेंट्स जो बाय
डिफॉल्ट इंस्टॉल नहीं होते। आप जैसे ही
सर्च करोगे फूड हेलपरx आप कमांड लाइन पे
भी एंटर करोगे तो इस तरीके से आपको दिखने
को देखने को मिलेगा। हमारी Windows मशीन
के अंदर भी देखो मैं एक काम करता हूं।
विंडो आर किया मैंने और यहां पर करता हूं
मैं
ई एल पी ई आर डॉट ईx लो ये खुल गया ये भी
ये वही है देखो व्यू फीचर्स उसके लिए अब
ये मांग रहा है पंप लेकिन यहां ये वाला
खुल गया ये भी हाई एलिवेटेड के साथ है ठीक
है देखो ये समझ में आया बट ये कि जो
वनेबिलिटी है ये Windows 10 के लिए है।
अभी तो ये वनेरेबिलिटी आप Windows 11 में
लेटेस्ट जो मशीन है उनको उसमें पैच कर
दिया गया है। इवन आप अपनी मशीन में यू आर
नॉट एबल टू बायपास इट बिकॉज़ इसको पैच कर
दिया। इसमें जो वनेबिलिटी थी। ओके? उसको
क्लीन कर दिया गया है। ये फीचर अवेलेबल
है। बट इसकी वनेबिलिटी को क्लीन कर दिया
गया है। बस ये एक्चुअल में वनेबिलिटी क्या
थी? यह आपको अभी दिखाऊंगा। समझ में आ गया?
तो वी कैन से दैट कि जो यह एक सिस्टम लेवल
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन हेल्पर है जिसका काम फीचर्स
को ऑन या ऑफ करना या फिर उनसे रिलेटेड
टास्क को मैनेज करना है। कौन से फीचर्स?
ऑप्शनल फीचर्स जैसे मैंने आपको बताया।
लाइक मोस्ट ऑफ द प्रोग्राम्स यूज्ड फॉर
सिस्टम कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस। फूड हेल्पर कैन ऑटो
एलिवेट व्हेन यूजिंग डिफॉल्ट यूएस सेटिंग।
सो दैट एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर वुड नॉट बी प्र्प
फॉर एलिवेशन व्हेन परफॉर्मिंग स्टैंडर्ड
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव टास्क। चलो मैं इसको
समझाता हूं।
जो डिफॉल्ट यूएस है देखो
डिफॉल्ट यूएस के अंडर फूड हेलपरex को ऑटो
एलिवेट करने की परमिशन दी गई है। मतलब यह
है कि जब भी कोई यूजर चाहे आपका एडमिन
यूजर हो चाहे एक ऐसा नॉर्मल यूजर जो एट
लोकल एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ग्रुप का पार्ट है।
मतलब उसके पास एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव टास्क करने
की एबिलिटी है। तो क्या करता है? जब भी वह
अपने नॉर्मल काम करता है तो Windows क्या
करता है कि Windows बार-बार यूएस प्र्ट
दिखा दिखाने की बजाय क्या करता है? कुछ
ट्रस्टेड सिस्टम प्रोग्राम्स को हायर
प्रिलजेस दे देता है ताकि जो
ताकि जो भी कॉमन काम है आपके जो सिस्टम्स
के उसके लिए बार-बार जो एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स
है या जो यूज़र्स है उसको डिस्टर्ब ना किया
जा सके। बार-बार उसको पॉप अप ना दिखे। और
जो फूड हेलपर exc है ओियर ट्रस्टेड टूल
में से एक टूल है जिसके पास ऑटो एलिवेशन
के फीचर्स या ऑटो एलिवेशंस के कॉन्टेक्स्ट
में ऐड किया गया है जो क्या कर सकता है कि
यूजर को बिना प्रप के क्या कर सकता है
ऑपरेट कर सकता है आपके मशीन के अंदर
व्हाइल वी हैव ऑलरेडी टेकन ए लुक एट ऑटो
एलिवेटेड एग्जीक्यूटेबल अनलाइक एमएसएफ
कॉन्फिग जैसा कि अभी आपने देखा था टेक्निक
वन में कि उसके अंदर जो एमएसएफ कॉन्फिग थी
उसके अंदर भी आपका ऑटो एलिवेशन का फीचर्स
इनेबल था। बट
फूड हेल्पर कैन अब्यूज विदाउट हैविंग
एक्सेस टू ए जीओ जीयूआई। इसका मतलब क्या
है कि कुछ ऑटो एलिवेटेड प्रोग्राम्स ऐसे
होते हैं। जैसे कि आपने देखा था कि अब
आपका एमएसएफ कॉन्फिग जिनको इंटरेक्शन के
लिए ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफ़ेस चाहिए। कहने का
मतलब अगर उसके ऊपर काम करना है तो आपको
जीयूआई एक्सेस करना है या आपके सामने आप
उसको स्क्रीन के स्क्रीन पे ही काम कर
सकते हो जो भी एक्शन परफॉर्म करना है
लेकिन वहीं पर फूड हेलपरex है उसका
बिहेवियर थोड़ा सा डिफरेंस है कि उसमें
ग्राफिकल कंपोनेंट भी है और कुछ ऐसे
कंपोनेंट है जो आपके lookअप पाथ आपका जो
lookuअप पाथ है उससे जुड़े हुए हैं। लुकअप
पाथ बोले कि डायरेक्टली आपके ग्राफ़िकल
यूजर इंटरफ़ेस को इफ़ेक्ट किए बिना भी कुछ
ऐसी चीज़ें हैं जिनके थ्रू आप मॉडिफिकेशन
कर सकते हो। मतलब जैसे बैकग्राउंड में
चेंजेज़ कर सकते हो। रजिस्ट्री फाइल्स को
चेंज कर सकते हो। फाइल को रिप्लेस कर सकते
हो। जिसके लिए उसको ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफेस
की कोई भी जरूरत नहीं है। कोई भी एक्सेस
करने की जरूरत नहीं है। मतलब क्या है कि
जो एमएसएफ कॉन्फ़िग है वो सब जीयूआई बेस्ड
है। लेकिन फूड हेलपर exc में कुछ ऐसे
टास्क हैं जिसके लिए आपको ग्राफिकल जीयूआई
इंटरेक्शन की जरूरत नहीं है। और सीएलआई के
थ्रू किए जा सकते हैं। चुपचाप बैकग्राउंड
में किए जा सकते हैं। खास करके रजिस्ट्री
वाले टास्क। ओके? तो अभी हम कह सकते हैं
कि जब भी कोई
विंडो के द्वारा जो साइन की गई बाइनरी है
अगर वह अपने एलिवेटेड प्लेजेस में रन करती
है। और अगर ऐसे में उस वह बाइनरी या उसका
जो एग्ज़क्यूशन एनवायरमेंट है जैसे उसके
रजिस्ट्री एंट्रीज हैं उसके फाइल पाथ्स
हैं उसके जो आर्गुमेंट्स हैं अगर उनको
मॉडिफाई करने की जो एबिलिटी है अगर वह
अटैकर के पास आ जाए तो यह सोचिए कि वो
क्या कर सकता है मतलब उसका पूरी तरीके से
मिसयूज कर सकता है। गेटिंग माय पॉइंट कि
फूड हेलपर exc क्या चीज है? फूड हेलपरxc
के पास भी ऑटो एलिवेशन का फीचर इनेबल्ड है
और सबसे खास बात यह है कि जीयूआई के अलावा
सीएलआई के साथ भी इंटैक्ट करता है। सीएलआई
में भी क्या है? बहुत सारे ऐसे इंपॉर्टेंट
टास्क परफॉर्म करता है जिनके साथ छेड़छाड़
किया जा सकता है। क्लियर यह चीज?
क्लियर यह चीज
7898 यह क्लास के एंड में पूछना बीच में
डिस्टर्ब मत किया करो ऐसी चीजों के लिए।
ओके? कांसेप्ट चल रहा होता है तो प्लीज
बाकी जो स्टूडेंट्स हैं वो सीरियसली पढ़ने
के लिए आते हैं। आप सिर्फ एक चीज पढ़ने के
लिए आते हो। मैं आपको जो चीज क्वरी है तो
क्वरी पूछिए बट एंड ऑफ द क्लास पूछिए। कोई
भी आपको क्वरी को रिजॉल्व करने से मना
नहीं करेगा। मैं भी नहीं मना करूंगा। बट
क्लास के बीच में ना पूछें।
चलिए नेक्स्ट चलते हैं हम। फ्रॉम एन अटैकर
पर्सेक्टिव इट कैन बी यूज्ड थ्रू ए मीडियम
इंटीग्रिटी लेवल, इंटीग्रिटी रिमोट सेल
एंड लेवरेज्ड इनू ए फुल्ली फंक्शनल हाई
इंटीग्रिटी प्रोसेस। अगर हम देखेंगे कि हम
नोटिस करेंगे प्रोसेस हैकर के थ्रू। हमने
देखा कि प्रोसेस मॉनिटर है। सिस्टम इंटरनल
का एक और टूल्स है जो प्रोसेस की काफी
डिटेल्स इनेशन शो करता है। जब वहां पर
हमें मॉनिटर किया हमें वहां पर यह चीज़
पाई। फूड हेलपर exc रजिस्ट्री इस पाथ पर
क्वरी कर रहा था बट नेम नॉट फाउंड ठीक है
जैसे-जैसे हम प्रिलज एस्केलेशन और भी
सीखेंगे Windows के या लinक्स के तो ये
सारी चीजें आपको छोटी-छोटी चीजों के बारे
में और पता चलेगा तो बट अभी समझिए कि ये
एक प्रकार से आप एक बिगिनियर लेवल पे ही
सीख रहे हो अभी तो यहां पर उसने देखा कि
जो यह fूd hxc है बैकग्राउंड में यहां पर
क्यूरी कर रही है इन इन रजिस्ट्रीज के साथ
क्यूरी कर रही है जिनमें एक थी आपकी
एचसीयू एचकेसीयू सॉफ्टवेयर क्लासेस एमएस
सेटिंग सेल ओपन कमांड इंटीग्रिटी इसका हाई
है रिजल्ट नेम नॉट फाइंड मतलब कुछ क्यूरी
करने की कोशिश करी थी लेकिन वो वैल्यू
एक्सेस नहीं की वो रिजॉल्व नहीं हुई यह
चीज यहां पर नोटिस में आई मतलब यह क्या था
यह उस अटैकर का लोकल रिकॉन है जो मैं आपको
समझा रहा हूं कि अटैकर ने ड्यूरिंग लोकल
रिकॉन फूड हेलपरexc सस्पेक्ट की कि कैसे
सस्पेक्ट की ऐसे सस्पेक्ट की और मैंने
आपको क्या बताया कि फूड हेलपर exc होती
क्या है Windows के अंदर उसने सस्पेक्ट की
ऐसे यहां पर उसको नोटिस किया ये क्या है
ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफेस टूल है बट ऐसे बहुत
सारे और भी टूल्स है जिसमें आपको आईडिया
मिल जाता है कि कौन सी प्रोसेस हाई
एलिवेटेड या कितने प्रिलेज के साथ रन कर
रही है। जैसे एक टूल हम देख चुके हैं और
भी बहुत सारे टूल्स हैं Windows के जिनका
हम आगे धीरे-धीरे यूज़ करेंगे। जहां पर
आपने देखा ना एक पूरा डिटेल्स में एक
वर्कशीट टाइप के डिटेल्स में पूरी डिटेल्स
आती थी कि कौन-कौन से पासवर्ड अवेलेबल है
नहीं है। मतलब बहुत सारे चेकक्स हैं। तो
उस टाइप्स के बहुत सारे टूल्स अवेलेबल
जिसमें ये सारी चीजें आप सस्पेक्ट कर सकते
हो। उसके बाद आप खुद से रिसर्च कर सकते
हो। मैं आपको जो चीज दिखाऊंगा ना उस चीज
के लिए आपको पता चल जाएगा कि आपको अभी
इससे आगे और क्या-क्या चीजें सीखनी है। हर
चीज मैं सिखा नहीं सकता। बट मैं आपको गाइड
कर रहा हूं कि आपको रजिस्ट्री की नॉलेज
होनी चाहिए विंडो के लिए और रजिस्ट्री के
साथ कैसे आप इंटरेक्ट कर सकते हो विद दी
हेल्प ऑफ सीएमडी वो भी नॉलेज आपके साथ पास
होनी चाहिए क्योंकि हम यहां सीएमडी का ही
यूज़ करेंगे क्योंकि सीएलआई में के साथ
हमें सीएमडी चाहिए। सीएमडी में हम
एक्सपर्ट होने चाहिए। जैसे Linux में
एक्सपर्ट है ऐसे Windows के केस में भी हम
एक्सपर्ट होने चाहिए। इफ यू वांट टू बिकम
अ ट्रूप एंड टेस्टर।
तो ये चीज़ थी। अभी मैं एक सिनेरियो समझाता
हूं कि यह चीज हो क्या रही है कि सर यह
हुआ कैसे?
यहां क्यों कर रहा है? इस रजिस्टर के साथ
क्यों इंटैक्ट कर रहा है? तो मैं हर एक
प्रोग्राम की कहानी बताता हूं। व्हनेवर
Windows ओपन ए फाइल इट फर्स्ट लुक इंटू द
रजिस्ट्री टू फिगर आउट व्हिच एप्लीकेशन
शुड हैंडल दैट फाइल। जब भी आप Windows के
अंदर किसी भी फाइल को ओपन करते हो तो सबसे
पहले वह उसकी रजिस्ट्री को चेक करता है।
यह चेक करता है कि कौन सी एप्लीकेशन यूज
करनी है इस फाइल को हैंडल करने के लिए। यह
चीज वो चेक करता है उस रजिस्ट्री में। और
रजिस्ट्री क्या है? रजिस्ट्री एक डेटाबेस
है दैट स्टोर सिस्टम सेटिंग्स एंड
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस इंक्लूडिंग फाइल एसोसिएशनंस।
फाइल एसोसिएशन क्या होता जो आपकेxtsphtml
pdf उनके जो एक्सटेंशनंस हैं उनका भी क्या
है उनकी सेटिंग सेव करके रखता है कि अगर
ttxt है जेपीजी है pngजी है अगर यह फाइल
को डबल क्लिक करोगे तो मुझे इसके अगेंस्ट
कौन सी एप्लीकेशन ओपन करनी है यह सिनेरियो
इसलिए जब भी आप किसी भी फाइल को ओपन करते
हो व्हाटएवर उसका जो एक्सटेंशन है वह जैसे
डबल क्लिक करते हो तो सबसे पहले रजिस्ट्री
चेक की जाती है उसके अगेंस्ट कि मुझे इस
टाइप के एक्सटेंशन फाइल को किस सॉफ्टवेयर
या किस प्रोग्राम के साथ ओपन करना है। नाउ
Windows रजिस्ट्री इज एरारिकल डेटाबेस। ए
ट्री ऑफ़ कीज़ एंड सब कीज़ ईच फाइल टाइप हैज़
ए यूनिक आइडेंटिफायर कॉल्ड ए
प्रोग्रामेटिक आईडी। जो Windows रजिस्ट्री
है वो एक हिरारिकल डेटाबेस है। मतलब जिस
एक ट्री की फॉर्म में जिसके अंदर बहुत
सारी कीज़ और उनकी सब कीज़ हैं। ईच फाइल
टाइप हैज़ ए यूनिक आइडेंटिफायर। अब क्या
होता है कि हर एक फाइल टाइप का एक यूनिक
आइडेंटिफायर होता है विंडोज के अंदर जिसको
हम बोलते हैं प्रोग्रामेटिक आईडी प्रोग
आईडी ये बोलते हैं जिसको हम क्या बोलते
हैं प्रोग्रामेटिक आईडी ये चीज याद रखने
की चीजें है कि जब आप विंडो के साथ डील कर
रहे हो तो हर एक फाइल टाइप का एक यूनिक
आइडेंटिफायर होता है जब भी उस पे डबल
क्लिक करते हो तो वो जैसे ओपन करते हैं
नोटपडxtc में ही क्यों खुलती है या आपके
पास फिर बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट वो खुलती है उसके बाद
या फिर ओपन एज करते हो आप तो वह क्यों
खुलती है। कभी आपने सोचा ही नहीं होगा
क्योंकि बिकॉज़ ऑफ दैट प्रोग्रामेटिक आईडी
यह चीज उसकी रजिस्ट्री में डिफाइन की गई
है उस एक्सटेंशन के साथ। थिंक अबाउट इट कि
छोटे-छोटे लॉजिक जो आपने कभी सोचे नहीं
होंगे, किसी ने बताया भी नहीं होगा। एंड
प्रोग्रामेटिक आईडी इज बेसिकली ए मैपिंग
दैट टेल्स विंडोज़ व्हिच प्रोग्राम्स इज
एसोसिएटेड विद ए गिवन फाइल एक्सटेंशन। जो
आपकी जो प्रोग्रामेटिक आईडी है, यह आपका
एक तरह का क्या है? मैपिंग सिस्टम है जो
Windows को यह बताता है किस फाइल
एक्सटेंशन का रिलेशन किस प्रोग्राम से है।
किस फाइल एक्सटेंशन का रिलेशन किस
प्रोग्राम से है। एव्री फाइल एक्सटेंशन
फॉर एग्जांपलxtmlp
pdf जेpgasp
हैज़ एन एंट्री इन द रजिस्ट्री दैट पॉइंट
टू द इट्स प्रोग्रामेटिक आईडी एंड दैट
प्रोग्रामेटिक आईडी इंडिकेट दी डिफॉल्ट
प्रोग्राम
यूज्ड टू ओपन दैट एक्सटेंशन मतलब हर एक
फाइल टाइप जो हर फाइल टाइप है चाहे आपका
टीxt है चाहे आपका html है आपका पीडीएफ है
आपका जेपीजी है आपका एएसपी है या व्हाटएवर
और फाइल टाइप सबका अपना एक प्रोग्रामेटिक
आईडी होता है। मतलब हर एक फाइल टाइप के
एक्सटेंशन की एंट्री रजिस्ट्री के अंदर
होती है। और रजिस्ट्री के अंदर क्या है कि
यह डिफाइन होता है इस पर्टिकुलर फाइल टाइप
को। इस पर्टिकुलर फाइल टाइप को कौन सा
डिफॉल्ट प्रोग्राम हैंडल करेगा? फॉर
एग्जांपल अगर मैं एग्जांपल लूं जब आपtxt
फाइल को ओपन करते हो तो वो नोटपड के साथ
ओपन करता है। बिकॉज़ उसकी एंट्री रजिस्ट्री
में है। हमेशा आपने या तो एज ब्राउज़र में
ओपन होती है डॉट या Chrome में होती है या
PDF की बात करें तो AOब रीडर में AOब रीडर
नहीं है तो फिर आपको देखा आपके ब्राउज़र
में ओपन होती है। क्यों? क्योंकि इन सबकी
एंट्री रजिस्ट्री के अंदर है। किस किसकी
फॉर्म में? प्रोग्रामेटिक आईडी की फॉर्म
में।
नेक्स्ट
एग्जांपल के लिए हम समझते हैं। देखो कि
फॉर एग्जांपल सपोज यू ट्राई टू ओपन एन
एचटीएमl फाइल कि आप एक एचटीएमl फाइल को
ओपन करने की कोशिश कर रहे हो तो क्या होता
है? व्हेन विंडोज रिजॉल्व फाइल एसोसिएशन
इट चेक एच की क्लास रूट इसको चेक करती है
एच की क्लास रूट। एच की क्लास रूट इज ए
मर्ज व्यू ऑफ़ टू लोकेशनेशंस। देखो जो
Windows की रजिस्ट्री है उसके अंदर बहुत
सारी हाइप्स होती है जिनमें एच की क्लास
रूट है फाइल एसोसिएशन से रिलेटेड
इंफॉर्मेशन के लिए एच की करंट यूजर्स है
मैं सबको बता चुका हूं ये यूजर्स की सेट
यूजर स्पेसिफिक सेटिंग के लिए एच की लोकल
मशीनंस है यह सिस्टम वाइड सेटिंग्स के लिए
ये तीन ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट होती है तो जो
आपकी एचके क्लास रूट है एच के क्लास रूट
क्या है यह जो एच के करंट यूजर है और आपका
जो एच के लोकल मशीन है इन दोनों को मर्ज
किया गया है। मतलब इन दोनों में से का
मर्ज व्यू किसके अंदर आपको देखने को
मिलेगा? एच की क्लास रूट के अंदर। मतलब जो
इंपॉर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन है, जो कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
रिलेटेड है, फाइल एसोसिएशन हो गया और भी
अदर जो इंफॉर्मेशन है, उनको मर्ज करके एच
की क्लास रूट के साथ मैप कर दिया गया है।
क्योंकि जो फाइल होती है वो सबसे पहले एच
की क्लास रूट चेक करती है कि पर्टिकुलर
फाइल एक्सटेंशन के साथ मुझे कौन सी कमांड
रन करनी है। दैट इज व्हाई। ओके? तो यह
देखिए नाउ तो इफ ए यूजर हैज क्रिएटेड ए
कस्टम फाइल एसोसिएशन इट अपीयरर्स इन एच की
करंट यूजर अभी यहां पर सिनेरियो यह है कि
अगर यूजर क्या करता है अगर यूजर कस्टम
फाइल एसोसिएशन बना रहा है। मतलब क्या है
कि कई बार आपने देखा होगा कि आप चाहते हो
कि मेरी जोxt फाइल है वो नोटपड की बजाय
किसी मेरे MS Word में ओपन हो या किसी और
में ओपन तो इनकी सेटिंग आप खुद से चेंज
करते हो आपने देखा होगा तो आप क्या कर रहे
हो कस्टम्स फाइल एसोसिएशन बना रहे हो उस
केस में क्या होता है तो सबसे पहले जब भी
आप क्लिक करते हो तो आपका जो यूजर की करंट
यूजर की जो सेटिंग्स है जो एचके करंट एच
के लोकल एच के करंट यूज़र्स की जो
सॉफ्टवेयर क्लासेस है यहां पर चेक की जाती
पहले प्रेसिडेंस इसको दिया जाता है कि
यहां पर आपने जो कस्टम डिफाइन किया गया है
फाइल एसोसिएशन वो ऑन प्रायोरिटी रहेगा।
अगर यहां पर डिफाइन नहीं है तो फिर आपका
जो सिस्टम है वो रेफर करता है आपकी एच की
लोकल मशीन जो सिस्टम वाइड डिफॉल्ट कि
डिफॉल्ट जो दिया गया है नोटपड डडी है XC
है या AOब जो AOब रीडर है पे उसको फॉलो
करता है उसके बाद उसके अगेंस्ट उस
सॉफ्टवेयर को रन कर देता है ओके तो हम
बोले कि तब भी जब भी Windows किसी भी फाइल
को फाइल टैब को क्या करता है? ओपन करने के
लिए के लिए ट्राई करता है। ओपन करने की
कोशिश करता है। उसके लिए उसको एक कमांड
चाहिए। वो कमांड कहां से पिकअप होती है?
वह कमांड यहीं से पिकअप होती है। एच की
क्लास रूट यहीं से उसको पता चलता है कि
पर्टिकुलर फाइल एक्सटेंशन के साथ मुझे कौन
सी कमांड रन करनी है या कौन सा सॉफ्टवेयर
रन करना है। यह सारी चीज उसको यहीं से पता
चलती है।
समझ में आया यहां तक? समझ में आ रहा है
सबको? क्लियर है यहां तक?
इंटरेस्टिंग गाइस
नाउ
अभी हमने एक एग्जांपल लिया था html का तो
व्हेन सिस्टम ओपन्स एन एचटीएमl फाइल इट
लुक्स इंटू
एच की क्लास रूट टू फाइंड द प्रोग्रामेटिक
आईडी फॉर html एंड देन डिटरमाइन द डिफॉल्ट
ब्राउज़र Chrome एज Firefox एसेट्रा टू ल्च
तो क्या होता है? कि
Windows सबसे पहले क्या चेक करता है? आपकी
एच की करंट क्लास को इसको चेक कर रहा है।
उसके बाद वहां से प्रोग्रामेटिक आईडी
फाइंड करेगा और फिर वहां पर डिफाइन किया
गया है कि कौन से प्रोग्राम को मुझे इस
यहां पर कमांड को रन करना है। अंडर ईच
प्रोग्रामेटिक आईडी देयर इज़ यूजुअली ए सेल
ओपन कमांड सब की व्हिच कंटेन द एग्जैक्ट
कमांड लाइन विंडोज़ विल एग्ज़क्यूट टू ओपन द
फाइल। हर एक प्रोग्रामेटिक आईडी के अंदर
मल्टीपल सब कीज़ होती है। उनमें से एक होती
है सेल ओपन कमांड। इसके अंदर डिफाइन किया
जाता है कि एग्जैक्ट कमांड लाइन
इंटरेक्शन। ये रहा देखो सी प्रोग्राम
फाइल्स इंटरनेट एक्सप्लोरर.exc परसेंटेज
वन। इसके अंदर डिफाइन किया जाता है कि
एग्जैक्टली कौन सा प्रोग्राम या कौन सी
कमांड रन होगी। जब आप डबल क्लिक करते हो।
कहने का मतलब जब मैंने डबल क्लिक किया
hटीएमl फाइल पर तो यह वो कमांड यहां से
रेफरेंस लिया। रेफरेंस लेके यह कमांड
एग्जीक्यूट हुई तब जाके आपको इंटरनेट
एक्सप्लोरx में बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट वो फाइल ओपन
होती है। ओके? तो व्हेन द यूजर ओपन द
एचटीएमl फाइल विंडोज़ रन दैट कमांड एंड
रिप्लेस परसेंटेज वन विद द फुल पाथ। और ये
जो परसेंटेज वर्ज है इसको उसके फुल पाथ के
साथ रिप्लेस कर देता। उसके जो उसके साथ जो
फाइल उसके साथ रिप्लेस कर देता। तो आई
थिंक ये आपको समझ में आ गया होगा कि मैं
आपको क्या समझाने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं कि
जो एक चीज आपने देखी थी ना इधर ये वाली ये
यहां पर क्यूरी क्यों की सेल ओपन कमांड
बिकॉज़ रजिस्ट्री में क्यूरी की जाती है।
रजिस्ट्री में क्यूरी और यहां पर ही
क्योंकि एच के करंट यूजर क्योंकि
प्रेफरेंसेस चेंज हुआ है कस्टम मैंने आपको
बताया था ना अभी-अभी अगर कस्टम फाइल
एसोसिएशन है तो कस्टम फाइल एसोसिएशन वहां
पर डिफाइन किया हुआ है। इसलिए यहां पर यह
पॉइंट कर रहा है। यहां पर कमांड नॉट फाउंड
मिला नेम नॉट फाउंड देन और बाय डिफॉल्ट
उसको ओपन कर रहा है। क्लियर यहां पर गाइस
एवरीवन यहां तक सबको सारी चीजें क्लियर
हैं।
यहां तक सबको क्लियर है?
चलिए
तो अब फूड हेलपर exc पे आ जाते हैं।
गोइंग बैक टू फूड हेलपर.exc प्रोग्राम वी
नाउ सी इट इज़ ट्राइंग टू ओपन ए फाइल अंडर
द एमएस सेटिंग प्रोग्रामेटिक आईडी। यहां
पर बाय क्रिएटिंग एन एसोसिएशन फॉर दैट
प्रोग्रामेटिक आईडी इन द करंट यूजर
कॉन्टेक्स्ट अंडर एचकेसीयू वी विल ओवराइड
द डिफॉल्ट सिस्टम वाइड एसोसिएशन। हम क्या
करेंगे कि यहां पर यह ओपन करने की कोशिश
कर रहा है। बट हम क्या करेंगे? उसको
ओवराइड करने की कोशिश करेंगे। बिकॉज़ हमें
यह प्रोज चाहिए। हम इसको मिसयूज़ करने की
कोशिश। देयर फॉर कंट्रोल वि कमांड इज
यूज्ड टू ओपन द फाइल ताकि हम यहां पर जब
भी डबल इस पर डबल क्लिक किया जाए फूड
हेलपर exc पर तो यहां पर क्या है कि यहां
पर जो हमने पेलोड प्रोवाइड किया है जो हम
पर्टिकुलर कमांड या प्रोग्राम रन करना
चाहते हैं वो पर्टिकुलर प्रोग्राम रन
करें। तो सिंस फूड हेल्पर इज एन ऑटो
एलिवेट एग्जीक्यूटेबल एनी सब प्रोसेस इट्स
फों्स विल इनहेरिट ए हाई इंटीग्रिटी टोकन
इफेक्टिवली बायपासिंग यूएसी मतलब जिससे
क्या होगा आप यूएसी बाईपास कर पाओगे काफी
इफेक्टिवली तो यहां तक सारी चीजें क्लियर
हैं तो आगे बढ़ते हैं तो नेक्स्ट
यह हमारा टारगेट है अभी हमारा क्या है यही
टारगेट है हमारा टारगेट क्या है यही
यही हमारा टारगेट है।
फिर से आगे कल करें क्लास में फिर गाइस या
फिर अभी क्योंकि इट विल टेक टाइम अराउंड
20 टू 25 मिनट ले लेगा यह कांसेप्ट अभी
इससे आगे कंटिन्यू करें क्योंकि आज
कांसेप्ट कंप्लीट नहीं होगा
इससे आगे नेक्स्ट क्लास में करें यस बोलिए
देव जोशी
बाकी लोग भी बताइए।
देव जोशी आपका सवाल समझ नहीं पाया।
नेक्स्ट क्लास में करेंगे। ओके? क्योंकि
देखो हमारे इसके जो सीएलआई बेस है ना यहां
पर तीन से चार ट्रिक मैं आपको दिखाने वाला
हूं जो इसमें यूज़ होने वाली हैं जो यूज़ हो
सकती हैं। यह सारी चीजें और अभी नहीं कर
पाएंगे। तो नेक्स्ट क्लास में मैं गारंटी
दे रहा हूं कल नहीं तो परसों हो जाएगी। कल
या परसों में से आपकी नेक्स्ट क्लास जल्दी
आ जाएगी। अब की बार इतना ज्यादा गैप नहीं
होगा उस क्लास के अंदर।
तो आज आज के सेशन में सबको इंटरेस्ट आया
गाइस। सबको मजा आया। सेशन इंटरेस्टिंग
लगा?
सबको सेशन इंटरेस्टिंग लगा।
देव जोशी देखो
एथिकल हैकिंग इज ए डिफरेंट फील्ड शोक
एनालिस्ट इज ए डिफरेंट थिंग दोनों के
दोनों अलग-अलग फील्ड है। मैं आपको बता
देता हूं। शोक एनालिस्ट आपका डिफेंसिव
होता है। एथिकल हैकिंग आपका आपका ऑफेंसिव
होता है। आप यह दोनों चीज बोल रहे हो कि
सर मैं कौन सा करना चाहिए? उनके कोई भी मत
करो।
ठीक है? फर्स्ट जॉब कैसे मिलेगी? फर्स्ट
जॉब मेहनत से मिलेगी। आपके टैलेंट से
मिलेगी।
आप जितने से ज्यादा से ज्यादा प्रोजेक्ट
बना सकते हो, जितनी ज्यादा आपके पास नॉलेज
है, जितने ज्यादा आपने पेन टेस्टिंग की
होंगी या चीजें सीखी होंगी, उनसे मिलेगी।
वो दिस इज नथिंग सर्टिफिकेट जिसकी आप बात
कर रहे हो। जो मैं करवा रहा हूं ना उससे
बहुत कुछ आ गया है। यह उससे बहुत कुछ आ
गया है।
जो मैं आप लोगों को करवा रहा हूं यह बहुत
आगे उससे
उसको करके आप लोग पैसे वेस्ट करना करने की
कोशिश करो उससे बढ़िया पैसे यूटिलाइज करो
सेव करो एंड उसके बाद
उसके बाद क्या करोगे आप उनको अच्छी जगह
यूटिलाइज करो अच्छे प्रीमियम कोर्स भी
यूटिलाइज करो जो चीज अवेलेबल है उसको यूज
करो यार उसके चक्कर में मत करो। उससे बेटर
देन मैं आपको प्रैक्टिकली बता रहा हूं।
रियली मैं मैं खुद अपना बता रहा हूं।
प्रैक्टिकल को इसको आप 48 वीडियो होगी। 48
वीडियो में कोई सिंगल वीडियो ऐसी बता दो
जो उसके कंपैरिजन में कम है। उससे डबल
कंपैरिजन हाई है। इसका भी फ्री में। ओके?
इसका आर्टिकल इस क्लास का आर्टिकल्स
यहां तक मैं इसका क्लास का आर्टिकल्स तो
एक साथ कर रहा हूं कि 49 क्लास के बाद एक
साथ कर दूंगा। एक ही मर्ज कर दूंगा। अगर
दो आर्टिकल बन रहे होंगे तो दो कर दूंगा।
अदरवाइज मैं मर्ज कर दूंगा आर्टिकल्स को।
49 के साथ ल्च कर देंगे। बिकॉज़ आर्टिकल
बहुत छोटा बनेगा यार।
समझ में आ गया? अगर दो आर्टिकल बन रहे हो
तो डेफिनेटली आपको कल तक ल्च हो जाएगा शाम
तक। अदरवाइज फिर 49 के साथ करेंगे हम
आर्टिकल ल्च। है ना? तो गाइज जो
स्टूडेंट्स मॉर्निंग में अभी नहीं थे
स्टार्टिंग में तो मैं बता देता हूं। हम
हर क्लास नोट्स को एक आर्टिकल्स की फॉर्म
में आपको प्रोवाइड करते हैं। तो फिर से
मैं आपको लिंक प्रोवाइड कर रहा हूं। जाइए
इसको अगर आपको अच्छा लगता है। जस्ट फॉलो
इट एंड गो थ्रू इट। सो दैट आपके पास नोट्स
भी अवेलेबल्स हो। एक अच्छी नॉलेज भी आपके
पास अवेलेबल हो। और ट्राई टू शेयर इट यार।
इसको इसको भी शेयर करो। आप जितना शेयर कर
सकते हो इसको भी शेयर करो।
ओके? तो एडवाइस ली है तो देव जोशी यह करो
उधर पैसे वेस्ट मत करो उन पैसों को बचाओ
और अच्छी जगह यूटिलाइज करो मैं तो यही
बोलूंगा अगर मेरी एडवाइस माननी है तो
अगर आपको पैसे यूज़ करने हैं कुछ एआई स्किल
में यूज़ कर लो फिर ₹00 कहीं एआई सीखने में
लगाओगे ना तो इट विल वेरी वेरीरी हेल्पफुल
दिस इज़ द फ्यूचर्स तो चलिए फिर सेशन को
एंड करते हैं किसी को कोई डाउट है सेशन
में बताइए जल्दी से। अगर कोई डाउट नहीं है
तो जल्दी नेक्स्ट सेशन में मिलेंगे। अब की
बार जल्दी मिलेंगे और हम अपनी 50 कंप्लीट
करने वाले हैं क्लास की जल्दी से। फिर हम
हैट्रिक भी करेंगे।
और डबल सेंचुरी भी जल्दी करेंगे। यस
Lindin पर हूं मैं।
यह होगा मेरा Lindin शायद।
यह जो मैं आपको टाइप कर रहा हूं, यही होगा
मेरा। Lindin पर सर्च करोगे तो या
डेफ़ोनिक्स एकडमी पर जाओगे तो वहां पर मिल
जाऊंगा मैं। जल्दी हम करेंगे। 50 जल्दी
हमारी होने वाली है। 50 के बाद हम जल्दी
हम सेंचुरी भी कंप्लीट करेंगे और अपनी हो
सकता है डबल सेंचुरी भी कंप्लीट कर लें इस
कोर्स में। और बहुत कुछ डेफिनेस पे आपके
लिए प्लान हो रहा है। तो डोंट वरी बने
रहिए। पैसे बचाइए और यहां पर ज्यादा से
ज्यादा आइए। ओके? तो चलिए फिर कोई डाउट
नहीं है।
अभी नहीं मैं लिखता। मैं Lindin बहुत कम
देखता हूं। मेरे को टाइम नहीं मिल पाता।
तो ओके चलिए फिर सेशन को एंड करते हैं।
बाय-ब गुड नाइट एवरीवन। सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट
सेशन। जल्दी से मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट सेशन
में क्लास 49 में और इस सेशन को कंप्लीट
कंटिन्यू करते हुए कंप्लीट कर देंगे। तो
सोचिए यूजर अकाउंट कंट्रोल के ऊपर हमने
चार सेशन दिए हैं। और चारों सेशन काफी
वैल्यूुएबल सेशन है। सबको पता चल गया एक
चीज़ तो। तो चलिए बाय-ब गुड नाइट एवरीवन
एंड सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन। मिलते हैं
जल्दी। थैंक यू एवरीवन।
बिल्कुल सी यू सून गाइस।